crime is becoming very an issue i know
people won't get on the subway
people rearrange their day around it
crime is out of control in new york city
when you get two lakhs these type of
things happen you know during these
times you know
you know people are desperate it's all
political
that's why he's coming
[Music]
i think the president can help like some
funding from federal government to help
the city you know the fight like gun
violence i think it's a total waste he's
going to do absolutely nothing to help
new york city if the president can play
the middle role but if he plays on the
side of the left and keeps talking about
the whole defunding agenda it's not
going to happen
political it's all political that's why
he's coming
for no other reason and to give
mayor adams
support i guess
every president there's a lot of um they
sell dreams
let's see what happens i grew up in this
city and
i'm 75 years old
and i cannot believe what's happened in
this city
as a new yorker because i have a
business here
is very challenging to have people
comfortable walking in the streets my
mom speaks to me every night she's
scared to go out
you know
unfortunately where she lives at prime
is up in the bronx oh of course crime
has definitely gone up you know when the
subways there are instances instances in
the bronx that i hear about
i never used to hear about all these
things even my customers they're being
being very afraid after five o'clock to
work in the city it's it's been a
problem since before kovid when they
passed the bail on discovery laws the
state legislature passed him cuomo
pushed him through and it's changed
everything
unfortunately a lot of people are doing
bad you know covet
when people don't have money crime goes
up sadly
no one is caring nobody's taking care of
all these issues
[Music]